a lot of girls do say how they prefer to
take charge and be that independent
woman being feminists and I think the
extreme feminists don't want equality
between men and women they want to take
over I haven't wanted to say that men
throughout history have been more
successful if they have big egos I mean
you have a big ego or it's toxic message
no they're egotistical just found that
people seem to label things that are
just like masculine traits as toxic what
is toxic masculinity
[Music]
I think toxic masculinity
is for I think this question is for
women not for men I think it's actually
and the reason why I'm saying that is
because
actually that that word well those two
words are actually what a lot of girls
nowadays are actually perceiving
themselves to be and I can say I'm
guilty for that definitely what do you
mean as in
a lot of girls do say how they prefer to
take charge and be that independent
woman have like
5K 6K what did they see you guys figures
yeah figures yeah all of that and to be
that I'm that girl you can't you can't
tell me what I shouldn't and what I
should wear type of thing I feel like a
lot of girls nowadays are doing that so
I feel like the whole traditional this
more than this I feel like the modern
times now is
awesome and taking charge being that
mass and a lot of guys will say oh yeah
that's so uh but it's like I wonder why
that it's because you guys something
most of you men just want girls you can
just control who's naive and he was just
nice and sweet he can just take
advantage off because it's easy for you
and it's less work no do you know what I
think you think it's hard you think it's
toxically masculine to want a nice and
sweet girl
I did not have to say anything to do
with masculinity at all I was going over
what she said going after what she said
she said yeah she was talking about taxi
what I said has got nothing to do with
talk to my words
I think toxic masculinity is something
that's been created by women that
like okay we have feminists yeah but
then we have the extreme feminists and I
think the extreme feminists don't want
equality between men and women they want
to take over and I think toxic
masculinity is like something that
they're throwing at men who just have a
really big ego thank you and they just
you know I mean you have a big ego oh
it's toxic message no they're
egotistical and if they're not for you
you don't want to deal with them then
don't deal with them but like yeah I
definitely think it's a phrase created
by women don't you think that men in
general have egos
men throughout history have been more
successful if they have big egos yeah
like the Kings the Emperors yes I mean
yes and no
yes I know I can agree with that so
explain go ahead so obviously like you
have to have a big ego to like be
successful to an extent but then there's
like being successful and then you're
having the ego but you're also humble
but then there's like really really like
super like egotistical people and you're
just like Ugh like you can't even you
can't even like have a conversation with
them because they just speak so highly
of themselves almost almost as if
they're like bigger than everyone else
and this goes for men and women because
there's women like this as well but yeah
just people that think that they're so
much better than everyone else but we're
all human and we're all like on the same
level I've just found that people seem
to label things that are just like
masculine traits as toxic yeah so a more
masculine way of dealing with problems
is to not talk about them we're a
feminine like as women like we want to
talk about our problems men in general
don't and so they'll label things that
are traditionally masculine as toxic
masculinity when it's just how men are
and I think it's kind of similar with
like the ego like I just think men tend
to have egos more than women yeah I do
know a couple guys that are not that
don't act out of their ego that are
really like they enjoy having deep
conversations oh wow so attractive
guy
my cousin he's no no he's very in tune
with himself he's like an old soul I
always tell him this I always big him up
for that he advises me on everything and
he's just amazing DMC big up because he
um
so I'm I'm curious do you guys want to
be married at all yes yes yes I mean I
would like to be married but it's not
something that I'm like super set on
like I have to get married in this
lifetime if it happens it happens but I
don't think
I don't think neces I necessarily need
like a piece of paper to prove like my
relationship with someone I don't know
but my parents weren't married so but
they was together for 17 years
um so you would be okay would you want a
long-term relationship then instead of
marriage
um I wouldn't mind obviously if I was in
a long-term relationship and I really
loved the person they proposed to me I
would say yeah but I wouldn't mind
whether we like had got married or not
so do you want kids I do okay and you'd
be okay with that in or out of marriage
yeah I'd be fine with that okay
um what about you do you want to know
truthfully I've never actually thought
about marriage like that but every time
for what I have seen on social media it
has given me like a put-off
right yeah but
as I said I've never thought about
marriage but back when I was little
Mario was a normal thing but now that
I'm older marriage ain't a thing like
that because divorce is more of a thing
that marriage should that that is the
reason why it's put me off but at the
same time it's like hmm I do want to get
mine but as she just said a paper don't
mean anything so it's like yeah I'm
still thinking on that one and divorce
means are expensive you know it's
expensive to divorce someone you know
for a couple of months
[Laughter]
is she going off of what you said I
believe that what if we're meant to be
we're meant to be no piece of paper
should Define it yeah yeah yeah so it's
like are you guys as long as we have
like an amazing connection marriage
doesn't mean anything okay what about
you do you want to be married you know
what I always juggle this topic all the
time sometimes I'm like yes like I'd
love to be all like loved up but all my
days
I don't need a title I feel like we
don't need marriage to obviously like
um
you know I mean say oh yeah my husband
I'm your wife like I feel like we don't
it's like I say I want I think I'm going
off more of the concept I want to be
loved up and I always I always date and
like relationship wise I'm a long-term
goal you know so I always that's always
like my intention like I'm quite
um loyal actually
so yeah I don't know what else I think I
love the whole but I do love the whole
black um proposal if you see my viral
proposal thing and McDonald's stuff
I was mad that was mad that was a prank
by the way I'm not getting married but
again I do love the whole like proposal
like aspect did you do a fake proposal I
don't actually oh no we did it blew up
massively that massively like literally
had a 35 million views in like three
days crazy I'll show you after yeah but
basically
um I do like the whole like the
beautiful like proposal thing on like
the rooftop balcony and like the flowers
and I don't know the wedding I think
I'll make a really beautiful bride so so
you you want the the proposal and the
wedding but you're not too sure about
marriage I'm not sure about the guy
about the guy the guy is well what if
you pick a good guy
and if he wants that and it happens
naturally yeah you know what I mean like
it's got you know it will happen
naturally I don't believe it should be
forced and you can't plan these things
and their relationships is a tricky one
it should happen naturally and like I
said should flow you know so yeah what
do you guys think that you need to bring
to the table in order to be a long-term
20-year girlfriend or wife and is there
a difference
um I think
stability
if you know you're stable within
yourself mentally financially
every Lee then then I feel like that's
all that matters and likewise for the
man if he's stable enough to be in a
relationship and to accommodate that
financially mentally physically whatever
way emotionally then that's that's what
so do you mean when you say stability
like financially stable yeah as a girl
you should be financially stable okay
don't don't just append everything on
the man you know don't expect because
when you expect things you could let get
let get let down sorry
I agree with that okay yeah go ahead
definitely in a relationship
um you also need to have your own funds
behind you you can't rely on a man
because then what happens if that man
leaves then if you're left with nothing
men don't leave
they always come back that's true no no
fun fact one percent of the time do you
think that women divorce or that men
divorce women I think a lot of the time
it is women that leave a thousand
percent what percent of the time do you
think women leave
maybe like 80 of the time yeah that's
true I think they're just when they're
over there 70 to 80 yeah and what
percent if you're college educated
there's only a 10 chance you're gonna
get left yeah I do think as well like a
stable stable relationship you know
bringing stuff to the table I think you
need to just like have have your
priorities in check you know again like
be stable financially physically
um and be healthy and cheap yeah so fat
people shouldn't find Love Of course
they should they should
definitely
most definitely
so you don't have to be in shape
as well as wealth you know if someone is
like really severely overweight and
there's people that has two severely
overweight people when they're in love
and like they don't they don't do
anything about their health how long are
they going to live for oh my God
my dad told me not to date fat people
because he said you have to take care of
them later
yeah you want to be yeah
like a serious issue so you should be in
shape you should bring that to it's okay
that's okay
it's important to care for yourself and
look after yourself you know a lot of
the time like when people are like
really severely overweight and like
obese and stuff it's because they're not
looking after themselves
okay so it's harsh like you call me fat
phony yeah but like yeah
we hate we hate cat phobia here yeah we
don't stand for a fat phobia at all yeah
like I'm not against fat people
I used to be fat guys but like at the
same time like I'm afraid I'm afraid of
fat people really yeah I'm scared of
them is that phobic what
I'm afraid of them
terrified
damn prep I'm yeah I'm like transphobic
too I'm all the focused
did not know that existed yeah yeah um
if you call someone fat they'll actually
be like you're fat
it's not no it's not like I think the
whole body positivity movement is really
important but at the same time if you're
severely overweight people like it's
your health at the end of the day it
normalizes obesity I think it does I
think it does and it's not it's not a
good thing because your lifespan is
going to be shortened because you you
don't look after yourself some people
are overweight because of health
conditions and like certain medications
and stuff but that is a very small
minority of people so
um back to the we need stability and
In-Shape anything else Financial
stability stability I think stability
also mentally is really important
obviously you can go through blips of
your mental health like during a
relationship and your partner should
support you vice versa but um yeah to be
in like a healthy relationship I think
like your mental health is something
that you need to prioritize
um anything what should women bring to
the team
[Music]
um
what should women bring to the table
themselves because every woman is
different so you should know in general
in general yeah in general
your true self of who you really are
exactly
that's true but if you're a loser yeah
what is your definition of a loser
coming back to what I'm about to say Do
not compare me to the next woman or the
woman coming after me because I am
different there's only one you yeah so I
should be bringing myself I have to
offer so throughout my 22 years okay so
what do you have to offer from your 22
years that's a lot we're gonna be here
all day so we'll come back to that
just give me three cool three things
knowledge wisdom and understanding
period done
okay okay uh go ahead you know what same
here like I said I bring a lot table but
I'm gonna be a bit more specific
freakiness is very important okay a
freakiness all right I would say but
yeah no um we've actually been serious
obviously yeah I'm serious about that
but I'm actually being serious
um it would be
um my mindset I think I've got a really
like good elevated type of mindset and I
think that what do you what do you mean
by Ella elevator no elevating no no no
no no I think like motivation like my
energy that I'm quite I have like a good
drive and a motivation I'm quite
positive optimistic so the people around
me and in my circle can feed off my
energy and they can all win in life
that's what I'm okay so you're you're
high you have high energy and you're
driven that's what I mean by like okay
okay yeah I'm just I'm trying to write
this down okay yeah it's really anything
else I would say
um
I'm good everything
women of many talents
okay can we can we name one okay
um
oh obviously we want to know I can sing
dance act sing dance act um um I'm smart
as well I'm good at balancing stuff I'm
not balanced up on my head I mean
multitasking yeah multitasking I can
balance a lot I can't do that
yeah like okay for example I'll take
example for a long time obviously when I
was I was 19 so obviously last year I
just finished sixth form but throughout
my I started doing for music when I was
like 16 actually so I started to me when
I was 16 17 18 but throughout that
process I was still in full-time
education so it was hard to obviously
balance like I'll do like a sold out
show with like and have like my manager
and like see Biz there and then I have
to be dragged onto that a table and
being told it was hard balancing what
all I wanted to do was fly so again
balancing is important and I still got
the Grays on white by end of it so yeah
well done yes okay
we'll give you okay
okay so I'm just gonna read back to what
what you guys said if there's anything
you think that there should be added
just let me know yeah being financially
stable in shape mentally stable
um I wrote themselves like knowing
yourself I think that was what I wrote
okay knowledge oh oh those you you bring
yourself
knowledge wisdom understanding
freakiness
um
driven high energy singing dancing
acting multitasking
to be secure in yourself as well you
need to love yourself that's the most
important thing
security self-love that's the most
important thing okay yeah okay can I add
something
um this is just my personal opinion by
the way I feel like having a source
like my my source is God my source is
spirituality my source is my intuition
so as long as you have a source then
that would yeah add to
oh no she means she means like a belief
guidance yeah yeah like religion yes
that's true that's true not necessarily
not religion not religion not religion
not religion not religion
spiritual spiritual okay I believe in
God though
okay so
stability Financial stability in shape
mentally stable bringing yourself
knowledge wisdom understanding
freakiness driven high energy singing
dancing acting multitasking spirituality
secure yourself
my question what my question was what do
you think that we women need to bring to
the table in order to be aware does this
sound like a traditional wife to you
anything I just read back to you does
that sound like a traditional way I
think maybe like a textbook
old-fashioned wife would be like you
know
um I think nurturing caring you know can
raise children can cook and clean
typical like wife like back in the day
Mommy caring so so why didn't we name
any of those things before because I
think we were kind of I don't know we
already know that point I was kind of
balancing like both men and women
women these are not honesty like the
stuff you guys listed sounds like what
women would want from a guy
women and men aren't the same we don't
look for the same things like women men
don't want dudes big blessing you want
to date a girl that acts like a dude
yeah but the reason why the reason why I
didn't mention
don't say that
all right guys I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna test something I've done this
before it's not just you guys last thing
would you want to date a girl does this
like sound like wife material
financially stable in shape got in shape
that's good mentally stable
um them bringing themselves to the table
knowledge wisdom understanding
freakiness driven high energy singing
dancing good at multitasking spiritual
secure and self-love that's the whole
package is there anything more but you
know what I was thinking let him talk
now say some of that stuff but the
majority what in particular sorry I'm
curious yeah what did you like from that
list
um I like the freakiness
I told you guys
[Laughter]
we actually look for like wifey material
like nurturing
um yeah we don't need you to bring
anything to the table really to be
honest um so you go with anyone then
yeah he's not trim yeah yeah
being themselves like he's going for a
girl oh yeah we said trees yeah
themselves honest yeah in themselves um
now some of this stuff is a bit
pretentious like you think so yeah you
think spirituality is pretentious
depends what what kind of spirituality
is it actually you know what yeah I need
to hear your answer properly you guys
just let him speak
yeah I think she's a point of
spirituality what what spiritually is it
well it depends for me I believe that
all everything is down to one so I
believe every God that they serve and
every religion is one God yeah I believe
that division is I don't know why
there's division in in religion but
that's that's up to them yeah but I feel
like everything all stems from or should
stem from love right love love is what
war oh yeah so would you date someone
from any religion then you would say yes
I actually would depending on their
mindset and how they perceive their
religion and how they believed like how
they understand it's all mindset it is
minds and yeah I would how would that
work in your household
um as long as we can compromise and you
know make sure that all the good aspects
of the religion are being applied into
our relationship
then do you believe men men are the
leaders of the relationship yes I do so
if they say that my children are
Christian or they're Muslim are you
gonna go with that I'm gonna be fine
with it my mom was a Christian my dad's
a Muslim so I was brought up in a very
diverse religion I guess I don't know
but I came out to be spiritual you can
say submission is what we're looking for
yeah
for submission you you are submissive
woman because I feel like a man wants to
feel like a man
he wants to feel like a man so if
there's a woman and like she's wearing
the pants and she's taking complete
control he's not gonna feel very manly I
have a question if a guy said to you
take that off that's too revealing Are
You Gonna Change are you gonna argue I
will question it so you're gonna argue I
would argue that's how they see it
that's how they see it you would argue
I'll crush it and try to understand
depending on the occasion on why you're
telling me to take it off because if I'm
going for a girl's not out why can't I
skin out and I would argue a little bit
because
a little bit of jealousy as well so I
would argue but then I'll still go out
in the same outfit
too bad
do you think that makes all of you toxic
yeah because you just said you'd be okay
with submission but when he told you
what to do you're gonna argue I mean
when it comes to telling someone what to
do like telling me I can't wear a
certain outfit because it's too
revealing like
he wants to protect you it's like but
the thing is is he protecting me from
other men or is he insecure and not
comfortable with me going out because
other men are going to look at me if you
have a nice car
I mean are you going to put a for sale
sign on it are you going to advertise
what is submission to you guys
I think submission is just being a
feminine woman like I really like in a
man yeah when he can like not take
control of me but take control of
certain situations so like say if we
like plan to go somewhere he planned it
or he can like make decisions for
himself but also for the both of us but
like within reason like certain
decisions that need to be communicated
between like both Partners yeah but like
yeah
that is no submission okay what's the
submission I think submission is when
um the female is very much in her well
she said but let's do that's the guy
like kind of um
so for you guys our mission is a bit
more sexual I didn't get to answer that
but submission is um abiding by the
rules of your um opposite sex so what
when he says oh yeah don't wear that
you're literally saying
something like yes sir I'm not gonna do
it because you have your reasons to why
I'm not even questioning it because but
you guys just see it right now that you
will not do it I mean it depends like if
you're wearing a dress and you're like
your nipples are happening I'm just
answering your questions
that if it's like a little mini dress
and you're going to the club of your
girls then I don't see why it should be
an issue but then like if it's like
something super like your ass cheeks are
hanging out your nipples are popping out
and everything
as a man is is that to lead his family
has a vision for his family so if he
says in my family in my household if we
don't wear that you're supposed to be
like okay yeah but if you guys are what
you're saying is no uh there's some
things you can decide but you say
something I said I said I'm a Christian
occasion I understand the reason why I
mean there's always compromise so what
do you think
submissive actually if then is this your
only one definition
you should actually just trust him you
can't even question it that's what we
expect what does submit mean to you
because I thought we stated it I feel
like I feel like that stems of
traditions guys the definition the death
the definition is the action of
accepting or yielding to Superior force
or to the will or authority of another
person so abiding by his rules so I'm
gonna decide whether or not if I should
abide by his rules
what do you think okay and women should
actually be equal but obviously let them
make some of the decisions about balance
you can't just say oh I'm gonna oh he's
a superior worship him
into account um I don't know how old you
are but like if you're an older guy
you're gonna have slightly different
like values like as a 20 year old 22
year old sorry
we want to go out and like have fun
[Laughter]
what do you think works modern dating or
old-fashioned dating old-fashioned I
personally I like old-fashioned okay
how how do you expect old-fashioned
outcomes in traditional courting and
traditional outcomes if you don't want
to act like a traditional women and
traditional women submit I don't know do
I no
if it works it works no but it's like
say for example like obviously like an
older woman she's not really like she's
going to dress a bit more maturely like
she's going to be more modest and stuff
I feel like in today's generation yeah
when we're young we always want to be
skin out and like wear these little
booty shorts why not look at me right
now if you've got it show it off
yeah but that's the mindset of like the
modern day generation like back in the
day like the housewives were not going
to the club and that is
I will say that you're not gonna get
like a you say traditional outcomes yeah
of course it clashes with the new like
you don't know of course it is because
you guys even when you're saying oh I'll
question him and ask him about the if
your boss gives you an order at work you
can't and your boss says hey this is the
uniform do you question him so why do we
question like why do we question we not
question our bosses but we're going to
question the person that we want to make
a family with I do question my boss
I question my boss why do I need to and
I'm sure you're his favorite employee I
actually am because of honest I feel
like that all depends on the types that
you give him as in you can actually make
your own definition of what a boyfriend
or a friend or a family or mum or that
could be
yeah explain that again it all depends
on the title that you give them all
depends on how you see them as in you
can make your own rules as you go
[Music]
if you want to lead the relationship
sure but like do women typically end up
happy when they're making the decisions
and making the rules and leading the
relationship because we allow our
emotions so so it's kind of like you
guys are saying you want your cake and
you also want to eat it too
I can see both no but okay okay
I could juggle both thing is I'm not
taking the rules and follow how do you
lead and follow at the same time
compromisation yeah so so do you want
every every single decision you guys
have a conversation about yeah like you
said every single does that seem like an
efficient way to do things marriages
aren't going to be perfect the same way
being boyfriend girlfriend ain't gonna
be perfect so it's like that is leading
up to it that's the whole I'm not I'm
not saying it's going to be perfect but
at the end of the day when you guys
disagree someone has to make a decision
and there's always somebody someone has
to give right and it's always going to
be someone who's gonna give there's
always going to be an ending who should
and and typically what I see nowadays is
is the man gives more he gives up more
and then we say the woman wears the
pants in the relationship no I agree
with that and so but the woman usually
hates the man when she's in a
relationship where she has to wear the
pants
in general women that are ball busters
that wear
you know you you're thinking of someone
I can see it in your face like the ones
that make all the decisions in the
relationship that are wet their
boyfriends whipped they hate their
boyfriends yeah they shouldn't even be
in a relationship in the first but they
need to go fix it that's what I'm saying
the mentality the mentality you guys
have that's where you're going yeah no
do you know what though I feel like when
you really love a man and you fall into
it you naturally do become
[Laughter]
fall in love with someone and you get
into a relationship with them you do
naturally as a woman become more
submissive I don't know like for every
woman that's the same with me like
because
you become more feminine it's only
natural
do you think that men are feminine until
they meet the right woman no so after I
become feminine afterwards after they
meet the right women to give you with
the women all day and you are who you're
surrounded by actually going back to
what you said I feel like the only
reason why a woman put up that old toxic
masculinity is by them protecting
themselves so they don't get hurt yeah I
agree with that that's true it's a
protection explain that again so people
um girls act bad and the reason why they
act like a guy is is because
they're literally protecting themselves
I don't know how else to like yeah
because they don't want to feel that
hurt again yeah you don't want to feel
that sounds like there's a baby
that goes to the concept it's like
you're making the men of the future pay
for the mistakes or your past yeah if
you carry it with you yeah if you're
acting like a dude so you don't get hurt
I mean like how many times do guys act
like girls so they don't get hurt
um experience of relationship to shape
who you are who are meant to become so
when you meet the right person you're
not going to be able to fall into the
same tracks
that's why yeah yeah
I mean there's a difference between
being naive and being traumatized
so so it's one thing if you're naive
right you can I can understand that
maybe not being so naive but it's a
different thing when you're bringing
your trauma into your yeah I don't like
the word trauma I don't like the word
trauma
nonsense
experience and your baggage yeah your
baggage into your future but it's like
you know how how do we move forward with
men and like actually get together and
get along with them if we don't trust
them well I think again like if you have
a lot of baggage that self-reflection
and self-healing that you have to do in
order for you to be in a situation
because if you get into a relationship
and you have a ton of baggage and
then you're pushing all of that baggage
onto that person who wants a
relationship with you and now they're
carrying your baggage as well as you it
becomes an unhealthy environment what
does healing look like I think no one's
fully healed okay but I think I think
through life everyone is healing
constantly constantly things are going
on in life and people heal from things
every single day you're never fully
healed like there's no definition of
being oh I'm Healed like I'm a healed
person yeah but if you wanted to take
steps to heal I would definitely look at
self-reflection self-reflection see the
things that have triggered me or things
that have caused me issues in the past
and how can I grow from that and how can
I work towards improving them so these
triggers don't affect me anymore and I
don't bring this baggage into future
relationships or push my own
insecurities and issues onto other
people because of my past experiences
what about therapy therapy is good but
therapy only works if you're willing to
do therapy if you go to therapy and you
don't want to do therapy then it's not
going to work for you I've just I've
done a lot of these shows and I just
found when girls say self-reflection
it's like nothing it's like listen to
some read some books put on some candles
listen to something I think
self-reflection I think journaling is
really important to write down how you
feel so then you can look back on it and
reflect on it and be like okay I felt
like this today yeah this is what I did
I might have acted out of character or
done this because again like looking
inwards is difficult it's difficult to
realize
and you see it from another perspective
almost yeah you're reading the story but
it's your story yeah you know I mean I
also feel like allow yourself to go
through whatever has hurt you in the
past yeah you have to that's the most
painful thing you could ever do allow
yourself to go through that again feel
those emotions that you felt when you
went through that you know so then you
could reflect from it Grow from it and
acknowledge it and see it like how much
you've changed because I'm sure you must
have grown from that moment as well so
it's nice to sometimes look back and
think all my days I used to be like this
but now I'm like this so again
journaling in aspect it's good yeah to
overcome uh blessing did you have any
more questions about submission for them
I feel like you had another one but I
kind of cut you off
uh yeah now I'm just gonna conclude and
say that we look for submission because
submission brings peace and if you guys
are not gonna submit to us we're not
gonna have peace and and then one piece
and if he's snoring he's snowing
well
what if what if your wife for example
feels like what if your wife for example
feels like what you're saying doesn't
really align with what she believes to
be right or true do you feel like that's
her going against you or that's her well
for me personally I would question it
I'd be like okay so why I wouldn't
necessarily want to have an argument I
wouldn't necessarily want to go against
what you're saying I just want to
understand from your perspective how has
that favored you in the past
um that means that you're not compatible
that means you don't have the same
vision and you're not aligned I'm a
Christian and and as a Christian there's
a story in the Bible about Abraham who
basically had a conversation with God
and he told him to just go
and that was just between him and God
and he had to take his wife his wife did
not know where he was going and she just
followed that submission she trusted her
yeah trust and bring submission so if
you don't have that that means you just
maybe just you're just not compatible
okay I actually agree with that
okay I do to an extent
what's your name again blessing you have
you're truly a blessing
truly a blessing at the end of the day I
think the main goal for a lot of people
is just peace you don't want arguments
you don't want toxicity exactly you know
exactly yeah didn't we start the show
and like we said you like toxicity
I have changed so much about this
podcast literally my viewership right
I've come from you know whatever that's
in the past now actually no sorry to be
the person but you can have peace and
someone can stay cheap behind your back
and just make it seem as if yeah it's
normal as long as I'm with you let it
affect you because you know you won't
let it affect you because you don't want
to you the difference there's different
scenarios you can be at peace but the
guys still doing stuff that you
shouldn't be doing and you're just being
submissive you get it so it's like yeah
but it could go the other way around too
I mean like he could like she could be
doing stuff that she's not supposed to
be doing well but like it's like as
women we're always bringing up the worst
case scenarios it's like what could go
wrong instead of what could go right I
agree with that 100 I think we have a
very very negative mindset when we get
into relationships a lot of people like
oh what if he cheats on me what if he
does this or he's sneaky
is that because of like what Society
reveals to us and you think that they
make men to be these villains I think
social media
social media there's a reason there's a
reason why we think like this we don't
just think like this like that out of
nowhere but you know what I think it
depends what kind of content you consume
on social media
culture yeah is very very toxic like
constantly like people couples arguing
people get influenced by it right you're
saying if you don't watch that if you
don't watch that then you're not going
to get influenced by it like social
media is a platform yeah and you can
choose what like what you want to absorb
and what you don't but what you absorb
it does have an effect on you whether
you think it or not like subconsciously
it does affect you I definitely know I
consume some really bad stuff
and you also control what you double tap
and follow it
I have a question I have a question all
right based on this conversation who on
the panel out of the four of you would
you want to set your brother up with
starting to go around I would want to
yeah
yeah okay based on like what we've said
about relationships sorry go ahead oh
yeah probably you you know you're very
spiritual like you're free spirit like I
love that go ahead who would you set
your brother up with
um because I don't know if you don't get
a brother just pick cousin a good one a
good one not
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay we'll do cousin
so I was gonna say you as well do you
know what you know why do you know why I
have a reason actually because I feel
like
similar morals I feel like you're very
chill as piece already there does that
make sense there's no you have to do the
overthink it sometimes you just gotta be
calm no no no I mean that just
I mean genuine
not too not much going on that makes
sense okay yeah I'm gonna take a second
to read who would you set your brother
up oh yeah
I'll tell you why spirituality not this
weird stuff
I need you to pick a religion or just uh
she's the following I don't need my
brother
she's not you guys both said you
wouldn't listen
[Music]
I don't know what's it you you got the
the nose ring I just don't like nose
rings
you cannot no you're just judging yeah
yeah that's too much
I'm no I'm judged off of what you've
brought to the show
and yeah yeah you can't judge based on
periods like everyone has many things
literally everyone has everyone everyone
judges okay
okay okay I come from so I come from a
one percent family okay I come from a
lot of men that a lot of like women
would want a date I grew up around like
the top one percent men in society that
make millions of dollars and I can tell
you absolutely men judge you by the way
you dress and by the way you carry
yourself so so yeah so when you're
wearing clothes they'll judge you
when you're wearing piercings they judge
you when they wear a ton of makeup they
judge you and so I could lie to you and
say oh they don't care but they do
careers
which is fine but if you if you want to
be alone that's fine but if you want to
be a lot like
if you're trying to sell a car why would
you not want to understand the buyer
so so for anything like if you want to
be alone fine that's that's totally fine
but realistically before anything men
always look at how you look oh yeah
they're not gonna if they're not
physically attracted to you then they're
not going to come and approach you and
yeah and it's the same for women as well
yeah yeah like it might not you might
have like oh like I go for personality
but like looks is always there yeah 100
it is and we judge them based on you
know their income like you're not I mean
you guys are young you guys are you guys
are young so it might be ambition or
driven but I mean I'm sure when I when I
was your age it was like is he in sports
is he doing something in the school he
used to be doing something right and
later that's going to translate to
income
um you know women judge them on their
height
women judge them based on how they dress
like if they dress like what do they say
a lame that's what the kids say lame no
story
[Laughter]
[Music]
um I'm gonna give you the super chats
though for a second
um guys sign up for her email list um I
know I've said this so many times a show
okay but we got a really cool Community
going on at Jess pearly things all right
we are going to be doing parties in
different cities we're going to do
meetups in different cities I'm even
thinking about matchmaking for like
traditionally minded people but I have
to build an email list I have to build a
base of people that want to be a part of
it we're also going to sell um beautiful
Majestic creature merch
but I can't sell it on YouTube because I
might get kicked off so sign up for the
email list
um also guys make sure you like the
video at a thousand likes we are going
to open up the chat and that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these streams so
Soros lost what if society called you
stupid weak and small for wanting a man
making more money taller confident
ambitious leaders stop shaming men for
our standards Chief Keef fomo of high
lifestyle lives are generally miserable
the UK Economist please ask your guests
what they why they think they deserve
traditional men if they aren't
traditional virgins black Moses thank
you Pearl for showing us women what
women to avoid none of them mention
peace they are all side chicks fellas
invest in cat food and blocks wine um 90
Frito pie it takes four women to answer
one question
um poppy her dress is so little she has
to cross her legs Zoro sloth most people
most of the women
Okay so
most of the panel is a prime example of
why 50 of women will be single and
childless by 2030 not being a hoe Being
Fit feminine friendly and compliant is
what keeps a man
um 90 Freedom pie women want lions with
no teeth or claws they want danger
supervised a redo button convenience
blank um they made a whole list of
expectations but we just want peace we
don't want to come home from a stressful
job to more stress afro so
um it seems like a younger version of
Esther I'm completely delusional and
toxic but doesn't see any of it in
herself um invest in chewy 90 free-toe
pie have any of these girls had an
honest convo with their parents about
marriage girls would be happier if they
didn't care about women's opinions solo
girl needs to match her foundation
zoro's the panel is side chick material
vjms everyone has lied to themselves
you're ultimately responsible for who
you choose to get into a relationship
with you